[Musique]
non
ces boulets français puis de melville
mais c'est mia mais non
vous allez adorer donc vous parlez
anglais mieux ça je parle de flic
américain am tourne trop déçu
danny glover est analphabète et solides
atouts locaux fois de plein fouet jam
access to it like frères pièce merci de
fly the blind side of life frère robin
yes plus c'est ce que j'ai dit
vous connaissez miami dont vous allez
adorer dans dix jours il retrouve mon
boulot pépère je veux pas des problèmes
les bienvenus
pause espérer que le reste de la police
française n'est pas quand vous
on suit ce classement les règles ça va
pas plaire à bien avec le règlement
n'est pas forcé d'être toujours eu deux
dents au kenzi que ça